Це не кадри з бойовика чи арешту терористів.
Так у червні минулого року група спецпризначенців
проводила обшук та затримання осіб, що незаконно ввозили до України
та підпільно виготовляли дорогий медичний препарат для онкохворих.
Подібні гучні злочини викриваються в Україні регулярно.
Підпільні лабораторії діють у підвалах, приватних будинках і навіть на фермах.
Асортимент підробок теж широкий -
від антисептиків
до гомеопатії і препаратів для хіміотерапії.
Про те, які ризики для пацієнтів, хворих на рак, несуть подібні фальшивки,
добре знає Ольга Фещенко.
Сім років тому вона сама
пройшла курс лікування від цієї хвороби.
А згодом заснувала благодійний фонд,
який допомагає жінкам з раком грудей.
Чесно кажучи, я раніше думала, що
ліки такого рівня не підроблюють.
є навіть випадки, коли підроблюється фабрика,
просто фабрика для того, щоб виготовляти ці ліки.
Буквально десь півроку тому була така ситуація.
Коли я просто дивилася, як було затримання
і вони просто швидко по цим лікам пройшли,
і я побачила, що там були ці ліки, які потрібні нашим людям.
Вони дуже коштовні, їх держава не закупає.
І це було страшно, тому що люди продають просто смерть.
Декілька разів Ользі доводилося виявляти фальшиві
та сумнівної якості препарати просто в момент їхньої купівлі жінками,
які звертаються про допомогу до її благодійного фонду.
Онкохворі змушені замовляти препарати за оголошеннями в інтернеті
чи навіть на стовпі поблизу лікарні,
аби зекономити гроші.
Адже лікування від раку молочної залози
може обходитись в сотні тисяч гривень.
Моя задача зараз, якщо дівчата купляють поза аптеками ліки,
вони мають хоча б візуально пересвідчитися,
але гарантій, що воно зберігалося…
Коли ти розумієш, що ти отримуєш фахове лікування
з тими ліками, що треба, - це одне, а коли ти знаєш,
можеш дізнатися, що це була просто крейда
або звичайний якийсь розчин глюкози, - це страшні речі.
За даними Всесвітньої організації охорони здоров’я,
кожна десята упаковка ліків є неякісною чи підробленою у країнах
з низьким та середнім рівнем доходів, до яких належить і Україна.
Деякі експерти називають цифру в 30 відсотків.
Водночас у Центральній лабораторії з аналізу лікарських засобів
і медичної продукції стверджують, що ця цифра не перевищує одного відсотка.
Саме тут можуть точно відповісти на питання:
з чого складається та чи безпечний лікарський засіб.
Ігор Лесик та його підлеглі на сучасному обладнанні щоденно аналізують різноманітні препарати
та вже знають, які з них найчастіше фальсифікують.
Якщо препарат має значну ціну,
то його дуже вигідно підробляти,
особливо якщо препарат не має відповідних способів захисту,
якихось там голограм,
флюорометричних нанесень і так далі.
І другий спосіб - це дуже популярні препарати:
сильнодіючі знеболювальні чи сезонні жарознижуючі препарати.
Усі неякісні ліки прийнято умовно ділити на три категорії.
Виготовлені на сертифікованих фармацевтичних підприємствах,
але з порушенням технологій; перепаковані ліки, термін зберігання яких сплив,
або ж ті, вміст і упаковка яких умисно фальсифікувалися в підпільних цехах.
Останні дві групи медичних засобів
несуть найбільшу загрозу здоров’ю.
Аби уберегтися від їхнього потрапляння в домашню аптечку,
Ігор Лесик показує зразки підробок
і радить, на що саме
варто звернути увагу, купуючи медпрепарат.
В першу чергу, я би хотів сказати про зовнішній вигляд таблеток.
якщо ви приймали яскраво зелені, а вони стали незрозумілого кольору, це теж сигнал.
Дуже важливо розуміти, що в заводських умовах
інструкція у нас складається машиною.
Якщо це будуть підробні ліки, то інструкція буде складене дуже просто:
склали один раз - два рази, другий раз-два рази і все.
У нас на одиниці лікарського засобу є номер і серія
і на коробці є номер і серія. Можна їх порівняти.
Якщо це все співпадає, то відповідно
цей препарат близький до оригіналу.
Окрім візуального огляду препарату важливо перевірити
в офіційних джерелах, чи він сертифікований
в Україні і чи не має заборонених серій
Це можна легко зробити за допомогою додатку
для смартфону "Ліки-контроль".
З ініціативи Наталі Гуран його розробили ще у 2018-му.
Тепер це фактично онлайн-база даних
усіх зареєстрованих в Україні ліків,
яка завжди під рукою
У ньому є покрокова інструкція, як навчитися перевіряти ліки.
Ми перевіряємо реєстрацію препарату в Україні,
чи він офіційно зареєстрований
Чи ця серія, яку ви купуєте, не є забороненою.
це може бути і неякісний препарат, який, наприклад,
самі виробники знайшли помилку на виробництві
і цілу серію відкликають, або це може бути фальсифікат,
або це може бути якась непередбачувана реакція
і тимчасова заборона до з’ясування цієї причини.
Якщо ж підозри про те, що препарат фальшивий, виникли ще в аптеці,
то пацієнт має право попросити сертифікат якості на цей препарат.
Експерти також радять
уважно обирати й саму аптеку,
адже перед тим, як ліки потраплять на прилавки, аптеки мають ретельно їх перевірити.
Відкривається кожна упаковка, звіряється по накладній по сертифікату серія,
щоб відповідала всім документам.
Після того, як проводиться ця вся перевірка,
тоді віддаються лікарські засоби в реалізацію.
Олена стверджує, що за десять років її роботи в комунальній аптеці
жодного разу до них не потрапляли ліки-підробки,
хоча траплялися пропозиції
від деяких сумнівних компаній.
На мій стаціонарний телефон
декілька разів телефонували
з якоїсь харківської фірми,
пропонували новою поштою присилати нам лікарські засоби в три рази дешевше,
ніж закупівля у нас іде у гуртових постачальників.
За інформацією Держлікслужби, нині в Україні
діє трирівнева система контролю якості лікарських засобів.
Є ще планові і позапланові перевірки аптек.
Однак чинним законодавством передбачено повідомляти про них за рік і за десять днів.
Це, звісно, значною мірою унеможливлює виявлення фальсифікатів.
Тим не менше протягом 2019 року
Держлікслужба заборонила обіг 16 найменувань фальсифікованих лікарських засобів.
Декілька місяців тому посилили ще й кримінальну відповідальність для тих,
хто підробляє ліки і реалізує такі препарати.
Тепер їм загрожує від 5-8 років тюрми до довічного ув’язнення,
якщо препарат призвів до смерті пацієнта чи інших тяжких наслідків.